[Musique]
non
bonsoir bienvenue pour ce nouveau numéro
du 7-8 culture tout de suite le sommaire
le 25 février la compagnie déclic
théâtre présentera sa dernière création
à la merise attrape écran noir nous
emmène en 2035 ou 6 oméga réintègre un
programme de désintoxication des écrans
à guyancourt la ferme de bel ébat
proposera également une création
publique pascal antonini adapte sur
scène la pièce d'edward opa flows qui
toile d'araignée l'histoire se déroule
en pleine dictature argentine dans les
années 70 sans quick n de concert une
quinzaine d'artistes le festival jazz à
toute heure revient pour une 22e édition
vallée de chevreuse une manifestation
qui a su évoluer au fil des années
éteignez vos écrans de smartphones avant
qu'il ne soit trop tard voici le message
que souhaite faire passer la compagnie
déclic théâtre à travers sa dernière
création la pièce et chrome noir sera
joué le 25 février à la merise attrape
notre caméra a pu assister à l'une de
leurs répétitions et si dans quelques
années notre monde hyperconnecté était
totalement dépendant des écrans pour sa
nouvelle création écran noir la
compagnie déclic théâtre met en scène
une dystopie qui se déroule en 2035
la surconsommation technologique et la
raréfaction des ressources énergétiques
qu'on traîne la société a changé ses
habitudes
cette pièce nous permet de suivre le
parcours de 6 âmes égarées accro aux
écrans il ya une de ces personnes qui va
être recruté par cette communauté
étrange en tout cas qui s'appelle screen
l'ess qui propose de désintoxiquer les
gens des écrans et cette personne va
animer ce village avec cinq autres
participants qui vont être les
stagiaires addiction aux réseaux sociaux
harcèlement numérique plusieurs thèmes
autour de l'impact des écrans dans nos
vies sont abordés au cours de la pièce
un travail de création qui s'est fait
avec des artistes associés la compagnie
trappistes a notamment fait appel au
metteur en scène laurent mazet il
viendrait nommé mais il a eu il est venu
souvent travaillé avec déclic théâtre et
on a des valeurs communes sur le théâtre
citoyen sur sur le théâtre comme vecteur
d'émancipation et de réflexion de notre
monde
en résidence à la mairie la compagnie
peaufine les derniers détails lors des
répétitions certains textes sont réécrit
avec les comédiens
martelly est d'écrire ce qu'ils veulent
pas le voir il faut arrêter de chercher
leur regard moi ça fait longtemps l'idée
du d'un spectacle un peu chorale avec
six personnages et six profils
différents on aborde en fait si point de
vue qu'on pourrait avoir sur le rapport
aux écrans et l'idée plus de délivrer un
message c'est justement de poser des
questions et qu'à la fin en fait ce
spectacle là soit matière à débat une
satire drôle noir acide et d'actualité
qui fait réfléchir sur l'omniprésence
des écrans dans notre société
partager une sortie au théâtre avec un
voisin qui éprouvent des difficultés à
se déplacer c'est le principe de
spectateurs solidaire le concept sera
lancé le 26 février prochain au théâtre
du vésinet à l'occasion du récital
d'alexander catch fsc binôme
intergénérationnelles sont composées de
volontaires et de seniors la direction
guyancourt à présent et plus précisément
à la ferme de bel ébat qui accueillera
les 25 et 26 février la pièce toile
d'araignée il s'agit d'un huis clos
familial qui se déroule en argentine
dans les années 70 une pièce engagée
comme vous allez le voir interdites lors
de sa sortie la pièce toile d'araignée
met en scène une famille argentine
durant les années 70
écrite en pleine dictature son auteur
eduardo peuple ce qui est un des
porteurs du théâtre politique un théâtre
volontairement provocateur cette pièce
est une pièce d'engagement une pièce
de résistance voilà qui met en scène une
famille argentine près dans une sphère
de renfermement sur elle même avec comme
toile de fond le football qui est très
présent là-bas en avant en argentine
autre thème abordé les jeux de hasard
qui sont également très présents à cette
époque cette adaptation qui sera jouée à
la ferme de bel ébat montre notamment
comment une famille perd ses valeurs
une pièce jouée en français et en
espagnol sur scène cinq comédiens dont
un argentin franco qu'abriel joue le
rôle d'un policier
c'est un sujet hyper fort pour les
sachants temps et c'est pas quelque
chose qui s'est passé il ya énormément
du temps c'est assez récent dans
l'histoire dans la mémoire du peuple aux
argentins c'est quand même très
intéressant de dépenser l'auteur comment
il a rédigé la pièce et comment avec son
parcours de psychanalystes rend ma
touche sa militance politique
appliquant sur cette pièce toile
d'araignée s'adresse à un public averti
plusieurs tableaux montrent les
violences commises pendant cette période
exemple cette scène deux policiers
rentrent dans la maison
on a appelé ça les disparitions de
personnes le régime avait décidé de
faire non pas d'emprisonner de fusiller
les gens mais de les faire disparaître
donc on a zappé et 70% des disparitions
se faisait à domicile
il y avait des intrusions on appelait ça
des escadrons de la mort deux
représentations seront données les 25 et
26 février
la deuxième sera suivie d'un débat avec
le groupe local de saint quentin en
yvelines d'amnesty international à noter
dans vos agendas cette conférence
organisée par l'association culturelle
plaisir oise lecture et dialogues le
jeudi à 27 février le chercheur jacques
tassant vous invitera à regarder les
arbres
autrement il dédicacera également ses
trois derniers livres sur le sujet et
c'est à partir de 20h30 au théâtre
robert manuel a plaisir
je vous le disais en titre la vallée de
chevreuse va vivre au rythme du jazz
pendant cinq semaines le festival à jazz
à toute heure revient pour une 22e
saison à partir du 28 février
plus de détails avec le directeur de la
manifestation michel beaucage marchand
n'est pas un festival 100% jazz que je
crée avec andré ceccarelli le batteur
français qui est l'un des meilleurs
batteurs du monde donc ça s'appelle jazz
à toute heure puisque en 1999 on était
pur jazz et puis au fur et à mesure des
années avec l'évolution des goûts de
notre public de mon goût de
programmateurs on a fait revenir notre
programmation de la musique du monde du
blues d'avoir qui est la famille
naturelle du jazz chanson française
puisque c'était une vraie pression chez
moi et puis bien sûr la musique du monde
qui sont souvent aussi associé au jazz
l'idée c'est vraiment d'amener des
artistes qu'on pourrait voir
habituellement sur les grandes salles
parisiennes à proximité il ya toujours
des nouveautés dans le sens où la
programmation essaye de se renouveler
tous les ans et à kylie a très peu
d'artistes qui sont programmés plusieurs
fois depuis 22 ans dans des à toute
heure
l'idée c'est trouver des artistes qui
vont décoller les prendre au moment où
ils sont haut de la vague qui vont
passer haut de la vague plus tôt et puis
bien sûr quelques références
incontournables qui font partie de nos
goûts c'est la première fois qu'on fait
du flamenco et ce niveau-là jazz et
twitter donc ça sera forcément un temps
fort notre part andré ceccarelli invite
laurent coulondre pour un hommage à
michel petrucciani
donc là on est dans le pur jazz masters
un festival qui est en tournée on est
sur huit communes de la vallée de
chevreuse de l'essonne jusque jusqu'à
levin donc on gif-sur-yvette jusqu à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines
saint-rémy-lès-chevreuse qui est
l'auteur historique du festival qu'on
associe la découverte de la vallée de
chevreuse patrimoine protégé parc
naturel régional avec qui on est
étroitement liée d'ailleurs et puis bien
sûr ces concerts qu'on amène dans des
lieux souvent qu'ils sont inhabituelles
autre style de musique cette fois ci à
montigny le bretonneux le groupe de r
bande airnadette sera sur la scène de la
ferme du manet ce sera le samedi 29
février les membres vous propose une
nouvelle comédie rock qui détourne le
meilleur de la pop culture nom de leur
spectacle airnadette le pire contre
attaque
voici un extrait
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
une douche deux fois pour être bien
propres après pendant une heure jean
photocopie du sommet j'ai tenté j'ai
fait aussi annie cordy
nous vous en parlions en octobre dernier
l'association manic oiseaux cinoche a
lancé depuis le début de cette année des
ateliers de courts métrages sur
smartphone durant la première semaine de
vacances plusieurs sessions ont eu lieu
et les films tournés lors de ces
ateliers seront ensuite projetés devant
un jury fin avril le but est de réaliser
un court métrage à partir de son
téléphone d'une dizaine de minutes sur
un thème qu'on a choisi avec la ville
qui ait la paix et les jeunes à cette
semaine dans votre avec des jeunes qui
de cap'ados du service jeunesse et ils
ont réalisé deux courts métrages dans
une semaine on a eu deux scénarios on a
une c'est un scénario c'est une classe
de 3e qui encourent en plein cours
d'histoire et qu'ils font vivre un enfer
à leur prof c'est leur prof après les
crises cardiaques et il essaye de
trouver une solution
on va terminer cette émission avec un
anniversaire le cinéma le grenier à sel
à trappes fête ses 100 ans cette année
installé dans un bâtiment présent à
l'époque médiévale la salle art et essai
a franchi les années sont cessé de se
renouveler comme le montre ce reportage
de grégory canale et de patrick jacques
de dixmude
il s'est appelé au cours de son
existence la grange de doueir puis le
normandie avant de devenir le grenier à
sel à la fin des années 1970 l'activité
cinématographique de ce lieu
emblématique de trappes et démarre après
la première guerre mondiale mais son
histoire remonte à bien plus loin
les prémices de ce bâtiment le plus
vieux de la ville sont visibles à la fin
du moyen-âge le grenier est alors un
dépôt de celles collectées par un impôt
la gabelle ce bâtiment a participé à la
à la gabelle donc à la à l'impôt sur le
sel est là la grandeur de cette bâtisse
nous laissant entendre que c'était un
lieu de stockage mais aussi un lieu de
vente
le site devient ensuite au xvième siècle
une poste aux chevaux un service de
relais pour le transport des voyageurs
et leurs bagages
l'histoire du grenier à sel est en fait
liée à celle de l'étoile d'or l'auberge
attenante
en 1919 le propriétaire du lieu demande
à la mairie l'autorisation de créer une
activité cinéma fixe à une époque où les
projections sont plutôt itinérante
les premières séances ont lieu dès 1920
la grosse activité cinéma démarre
officiellement avec en 1945
sorti de la guerre où le cinéma ou la
grange devient le normandie le cinéma le
normandie et le normandie s'arrête
en 1975 puis 6 puis le bâtiment est
repris par la ville
restauration en 1979 qui laisse
apparaître les pierres meulières du
bâtiment encore visibles aujourd'hui un
lieu avant tout d'innovation
technologique le cinéma inaugure en 1964
un écran révolutionnaire le deuxième du
type installé dans le monde l'heracles
orama c'était un écran courbes avec des
lamelles en métal qui permettait d'avoir
avec un certain objectif qui permettait
d'avoir une impression de profondeur
donc on pouvait projeter n'importe quel
film du commerce et avoir une impression
de profondeur s'était pas le relief
encore mais c'était déjà une grande
avancée technologique en 2012 le grenier
à sel s'équipe d'un projecteur 4k l'une
des premières salles à se convertir à
l'ultra haute définition elle malgré son
grand âge le cinéma de trappes n'a cessé
de se renouveler un oeil toujours tourné
vers l'avenir
voilà c'est la fin de ce cette fille
culture merci de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve mardi prochain pour un nouveau
numéro
[Musique]